中大胆周报
欢迎收看中大胆周报
公开版279G
还记得上一集中大胆提醒
当市场的气氛变成超级积极的时候
我们的心肔要比较安定
所以我们看到近一个礼拜
果然指数有稍微做了压回
压回中大胆的选股方向
也是以帮大家报值为主
真的是很厉害
但接下来的走势呢
很厉害喔
还会再压回吗
什么时候我们才能比较放心呢
我们这波的指数
真的如我自己所预期规划
时间呢
我自己把握的是两周
超过两周我真没把握
我都会跟各位投资朋友讲真的
因为我自己算大概就在8月14号
中旬左右
就是我可以掌握得到
这次没办法掌握到
就是MSCI的三升
这个确实是超乎我的疫情
所以呢
45000到46000本来就是我之前认为说
这边应该是比较会能达到的位置区
甚至我认为46350应该就是极限
那空间呢46000左右
把盘式讲成这样子时间空间都给你讲好了
我看应该很少人会像我讲的那样的
仔细
而且没有什么假如看看外资有没有怎样
假如看看军量有没有一兆
我不用跟你讲那样子
我就直接给你讲答案
时间就那个时间
空间就那样子
把手中持股适当的降比例
你应该就会发现到
你的操作上应该是
算是还能够掌握到节奏
那这个礼拜来讲的话
重点是在于
我要跟各位讲是
投信很少限在8月17号
大卖超177亿
这个将近会确认是
晋级的投步区
为什么呢
我想我们先来看一下
投信最近卖超百亿元以上的
827、177亿好像是历史上最大的
真的是蛮多的
那请问各位8月17号
我们8月16号第261集
刚好就是在卖超的前一天
所以我如果是在投信大卖超完之后
跟你讲那叫头部
那叫做我是落后者
这投信还卖还没卖
我就跟你讲
到了那个位置一定要调降此故比例
我真的觉得有时候投信真的有在看我们节目
毕竟投信是你的好朋友
有时候思维会刚好就match在一起
我觉得我真的
我觉得我们就发现
如果是偶尔一次
那就但是刚好
偶尔一次可能是臭小
如果是每一次都有这样子
那真的就不是臭小
那真的是我的思维
真的跟投信的思维很像
逻辑一致
这礼拜来讲
除了177以外
紧接着隔了两天之后
又卖了100多亿
换句话说
他在这个礼拜就大卖了将近两天有所谓的百亿元以上
那表示这个位置区就是投信他认为相对高档
上一次呢6月12号105亿
卖超了前一天277级奖
然后就是那次廉价完之后
见到48218的位置
也是刚好我奖完之后
投信那一天又开始卖
所以呢
你会发现从这样的现况有一个情况就是
投信上次卖超百亿的时候
刚刚就四百亿八就是高点
那这次呢
投信在四万六千多点左右
卖超两次的百亿元
那比上次那个还大薄
那现在位置要比当时候的位置
少了将近快两千点
那表示什么
这个位置基本上四万六到这波的高点
不管怎样子相对就是一定是高
所以如果这样的话你就很清楚
4万6你都不用想会到哪边去因为投信用心弄证明这两次他卖了白亿元但你说有没有看错的有 1月19号我记得年初年前的时候
那时候卖了130亿
后来发现卖下去跌不下去
然后又干嘛 再买回来
所以这个大盘
如果要能够过46350
这个签钱更高点的话
表示什么
投信这个礼拜
分别卖的那两天的
百亿元以上将近三百亿
全部认错买回来
三百亿对头现在来讲
不是那么算是小数字
算是蛮大的数字
所以我想这个淡数就很清楚的告诉你
四万六附近你就卖掉
手中持股比例再降低
那现在已经从手中的持股
从五成降到四成
图上有划两条黄线
一条的上升趋势线
应该就是这波的四万六的位置点
另外一个就是上升趋势线
看起来一个是在4万6
一个在4万2
如果你真的要买
我还在跟你考虑4万4
就是4万6跟4万2的中间
4万4附近买
你相对空间比较大
因为你4万5千多天
你买坦白讲
空间就不到1%
你不到那1%
在那边每天看盘
看得要
看得很辛苦
坦白讲
那绝对不是
我所认识的大户主力
他会想要进来的
只有少数客定的买盘会进来
那外资呢
先前大买超
它已经成为这一波的潜在
卖压的部位了
但是空单
我看也没有明显的降低
换句话说
它比较偏向是短多的操作
投信呢
高档卖大于买
那客数的买盘在高档观望
所以呢
指数就等于拉回到文件区
你才考虑做买进
高楼的套房
已经住了那么久
而且高楼的套房
都是六月的人去借了很多钱的人去用的
那你要想
那一波借钱的人都已经没有钱可带了
那这一波要再进去买的人
坦白讲
也不可能会在这个时候位置进
如果是一个市场上的老手超盘手的话
我一定什么
这一波先获利完之后
再蹲下去多一点
我再重新再上车
这样空间才会大
怎么样
该是老手的厉害的
4万2以下早就该进来
这时候4万6再进去
那不叫做厉害的
那叫做落后的
先前套牢量我认为说
还是需要用以盘的方式代替
这是最好的方式
如果真的要买进的话
我认为4万4附近
在从原先在4万6附近卖的
然后在4万4的时候
再把4成加到5成
为什么
因为4万4是投信主要的成本位置区
所以你这样就很清楚
那如果你在46000到44000这样的话
这样有2000点
这样空间就大了
那等到指数回到长期的稳健区
来到43000
你就似乎提高到六成到八成
超级稳健区就到八成到九成
我相信投信应该也是有类似这样的想法
因为在这位置
反正他42000、43000、43000买那么一堆
他这时候不卖
他卖给谁
这当然这时候适当地做调解
我还是再强调一下
这张是我们之前在7月底的时候
8月初的时候
给各位看
7月底8月初会做跌升反弹
然后7月的跌幅
8月跌幅不容易超越过去的经验
告诉你7月的跌幅
8月份的涨幅不容易过一半
因为下个礼拜基本上就应快进到月底了
所以如果按照这样的算的话
那么44525以上都是结满好时机
禮拜五的時候在4萬5千多點
我還是認為有高檔 有能拉起來
你就讓你適當做一個出場
當然有一些部分像傳統產業股因為籌碼整理已久你就看市場上的资金变化因为毕竟现在资金有部分从电子转到航运或转到其他的一些
高股息质率率个股去
所以还是想要
如果按照过去这10年当中的经验
你正常下个礼拜
来到44525以下
应该算是合理的部分
那这张图也是一样
我们每一个礼拜
差不多会跟你做一个update
就这么巧 就来到46,500点附近
上次跟各位讲来到超级积极区
你一定会很积极
但是如果你看图你就知道
来这个位置好像是不应该积极的
所以我们上礼拜有提醒大家
要从这个五成降到四成
那你看现在就是进行式是这样子
我还是强调一下
我都是讲在前面
我不是给你讲在后面
讲在后面你现在要卖46,000很难
讲在前面你还可以卖在46,000
甚至还更高
所以这波就等拉回
如果真的有机会来到那黄色线
4万3
你应该遇到当时候的利空
应该说真好有好利空
让你一个有低点可以买
所以你要很清楚你就会知道
因为最近你有发现
电子的利多发布常常变成什么
被到货
利多不是利多变成是利空
那这样子情况来讲
你会发现
在这一波你在4万6的操作
你的思维不同
你的策略就不同
所以预测不同
如果你是预测48000
过更高压力
我相信你会持股会加码
因为会有48000
所以你会再加码
或是你没有钱
你就可能持股比例不动
但是如果像我预期
45000或46000
投资会员你有听我的建议的话
你有持股加码
你未来就等大幅回档的时候
再做加码动作
我看有些网友就写
那干嘛这么进进出出
坦白讲确实啦
如果你就做它破断了
确实是不用那种进进出出
有些人可能本来他的持股就低成本
对不对
他想长期持股那确实不用啊
确实不用
所以有两种
一种是你续报等五万点
那我再跟各位讲
五万点不会在这时候发生的
绝对不会在那个时候发生的
因为你要想
会借钱的人都已经借光了
不会借钱的就不会借钱
所以这段时间
你不要想得太天真
用盘代替就已经是一个不错的方式
那另外一种就像我们这种方式
你等拉回超过2000点再低接
2000点对于现在这个大盘
这个大概近45,000
46,000大概多少
4%到5%
其实4%到5%的获利空间
也算是不小
你可以适当的降成本
或者是增加你的获利
所以我想这个部分是
你要做一个
看你个人的思维是这样
我个人认为说
5万点一定会到的
但是呢 不会这时候
不过还是要看你有没有报对股票
如果没报对股票
你搞不好还会被这波市场上的资金移转所淘汰掉
这波我觉得观察重点应该会是在上柜
为什么呢 各位如果可以注意到
这一波的上柜来到季向附近就踩刹车
那踩了刹车完之后呢
这个大盘外资D跟KK就是在季向附近卖
换句话说
有一些外资在这个上柜来到
季线布进达到目的的时候
就已经就出场
投信是在第二根黑黑
跟着外资做一个调节动作
那各位投资本要去注意到一件事情
是投信呢
从我图上各位可以看清楚
投信在之前连续买了四天的上柜
他的金额大概买了将近152亿
到目前为止
他调节的动作没有很像上市那么大
那整个收盘指数是387点他那时候的四天的最低的买的点数位置大概落在386点32点换句话说基本上可以笃定
投信应该在上柜这边是有一些金额是套牢的部分
那这一波呢
季线目前稍微走平为弯
现在呢
季线的位置将要扣底
5月底6月初那时候高档位置去
换句话说
接下来上柜
除非资金有再轻一批的资金
愿意再进来
否则来讲
大概到下个礼拜
或甚至到9月份
OTC的季限的下弯的幅度
就会更明显
因为这波的OTC是涨比较多
你想一想
如果你是在低档
大概在年线附近买的人
到目前应该是赚的
比上市还多
这时候你是要坚定
四成五成获利
我不出场
那我就认为这个大盘往上攻
否则以人性来讲
又创新低量化
我认为赚了四成五成的人
加加减减应该是
会把手中的一些持股
把它做一些调节
那最近大盘大家认为说
股市会下跌
可能跟美日欧的
常债殖利率上扬有关
确实它现在已经在高档
你会发现有时候有一天会压回
但是你不管有没有压股
如果講它就相對是再高
如果以美國的30年期的美債殖利率
大概5%左右
我請問各位
如果你就是4萬5年買
那你到4萬6
大概不到1000
大概就大概1000點左右
這個大概大概1%到2%
你1%2%就獲利
絕對不會馬上買美債殖利率這邊安全
所以你就知道為什麼
最大的市場上的思維
它不是在賺那個資本價差
它現在很清楚說
如果任何状况
我美债责利率我5%
比这个操作5%来的安全
除非就是现在4万6
你涨5%就来到4万8
那当然市场上就会考虑
那我做美债可能就不是那么妥当
否则以现阶段
短期不容易来到4万8的话
来到4万6我就觉得很辛苦
那赚1%2%跟美债责利率5%
摆在那边就很清楚
市场上的钱就会parking在这块
所以呢
等个全球的股市
没有走向一个
比较强而有力的
这个攻击力道的话
那我认为说
现阶段市场上资金
应该会部分的资金
会跑到在那边去等待
因为最近这个5%
市场相对是安全多了
但是台湾的股票
也有5%的殖利率
很多的公司
我想上礼拜
我们就开始已经转移到
防御型的公司
我想这礼拜也
会恭喜我们投资朋友
也在这个当中
电子股还没走落之前
我们先转到传三股去做一个等待
是
好当然如果各位朋友
本来就是很稳健型的
很多的持股是买在低成本
是要报很久或是持续累积的
不用听这么短的变化
确实是如此
可是有更多的朋友有发现到
非常在意大盘的高低
像我自己如果要买东西
我也会注意啊
中大胆已经提醒
这边是高位街区了
我就不要在这个时候硬买
下来的时候可以买更多不是吗
所以用累积的人
其实中大胆的预测
也是非常实用的
那当然因为这是大盘
个股的部分
为什么能够提早把电子股的想法
转到比较高息的传产股去避风
这个就是选股功力了
所以如果认同中大胆理念的朋友
也欢迎订阅我们的VIP
因为我们这一集的VIP
一样也是要把这个台股
接下来的走势跟大家讲清楚之外
也要告诉大家钱放在哪里
您是最安心的
我会把订阅的连结放在留言的第一栏
我们就VIP见啰
字幕志愿者 杨茜茜